[Music]
hey i'm edgar wright i'm the director
and co-writer of last night in soho and
i'm chatting with the academy the title
of the film comes from the song by dave
d dozy beaky mckentich i was first put
onto by quentin tarantino he said this
is the best end titles music for a film
that's never been made this is like 10
years ago first it was just soho project
then it became like red light area and
then i decided to call it the knight has
a thousand eyes and then eventually it
was just staring me in the face last
night in soho that's the title so i
changed the title and i said did you see
the title of my movie and he goes yes i
said are you annoyed at me he goes no he
goes i thought if anybody could make a
movie of that title it's you and i said
well i'm gonna thank you at the end of
the movie guys well if you thank me you
have to thank alice hernandez because
she's the one who put me onto it and
she's the one who said this is the best
end title music for a film that doesn't
exist so now alice hernandez and quentin
tarantino are both thanked and she was
so thrilled she sent me a seven-inch
single of last night in soho which is
now on my mantelpiece and that is full
circle
you